how is obi-wan being lured into an
elaborate trap and what's inquisitor
riva's obsession with hunting down the
jedi all about
keep watching to learn all that the
second episode of obi-wan kenobi on
disney plus revealed
warning spoilers for the first two
episodes are ahead
when obi-wan first arrives on the murky
planet daiyu he quickly finds that he
can't track the ship of the bounty
hunters who have kidnapped leia the
empire has blocked all incoming and
outgoing signals as a way of restricting
any force sensitives on the planet
cutting off communications is a useful
tool for the grand inquisitor as it
isolates those who really need help and
makes it more likely that they'll reveal
themselves by accident but criminals
have already capitalized on this
opportunity enter hajja estri estri is a
trafficker who claims to be a jedi to
help smuggle people off planet but he
just uses magnets to fake his force
powers as a way of getting the helpless
to trust him
the force is so strong with you yeah i
know
then he charges them an exorbitant
amount of credits to escape daiyu
obi-wan isn't exactly impressed with
estrie's money-making scheme and forces
him to help uncover the location of the
kidnapped leia
it's clear that estria is trying to make
ends meet in a difficult situation and
he does seem a little remorseful when
kenobi calls him out for exploiting the
innocent kumail nanjiani who plays
estuary sells it with the perfect amount
of smarmy charisma hodges information
pays off
and obi-wan finds leia at a spice den
what obi-wan doesn't realize however is
that this has all been an elaborate trap
obi-wan is doing the right thing by
helping bail organa get his adopted
daughter back he's also putting himself
in extreme danger thanks to the
increased presence of the inquisitors
riva has carefully planned this
kidnapping plot to lure obi-wan out of
hiding and unfortunately it works pretty
well after obi-wan frees leia the duo
quickly draws plenty of attention thanks
to the young princess's feisty behavior
it doesn't help that riva also puts a
bounty on obi-wan so big it puts the
entire planet on the lookout for the
rogue jedi plus obi-wan underestimates
how free-thinking leia really is she's
been desperate to see life outside of
alderaan so it's understandable that
she's so curious about everything on
diet leia's inquisitive nature leads her
to question obi-wan in a personal way
that he isn't prepared to address after
questioning her savior's jedi
qualifications
it's just
you seem kind of
old and beat up
she runs off not out of obstinance but
because she figures out the outline of
the plan to catch a rescuer even as a
young girl princess leia of alderaan is
nobody's bait the chase quickly
culminates in a rooftop shootout between
obi-wan and various gunmen while leia
falls from a building this pushes
obi-wan to tap into his dormant force
powers to save the young girl a bit
remorseful over his deceptions hadja
stream makes amends estri gives the jedi
a way off daiyu using an automated cargo
ship bound for a planet called mapuzo
where there are apparently people who
will help them though given estrie's
trustworthiness to this point that
information is unreliable at best it
isn't long before riva and the grand
inquisitor catch up to the escapees the
grand inquisitor reprimands the third
sister for not following orders and
acting on impulse in response riva
decides to show him exactly what impulse
looks like with a lightsaber through the
gut it seems unlikely that the grand
inquisitor is dead as this would be a
major retcon of cherished star wars
canon this character's death happens
much later in the star wars rebels
season 1 finale fire across the galaxy
it's not impossible that lucasfilm has
decided to break canon in this way but
it seems more likely that the inquisitor
will find some way to return and pursue
vengeance against riva
it will not change what you are
and what is that
the least of us
for the moment it's not clear why riva's
so desperate to catch obi-wan but a
leading theory is that she was one of
the apprentices who escaped the jedi
temple during the acute phase of order
66.
why else show us that flashback at the
beginning of the series
perhaps riva resents obi-wan for leaving
her behind which would also explain why
she's allied herself with darth vader
whom obi-wan left to burn on mustafar at
the end of revenge of the sith
the episode only gives us a brief
glimpse of vader's soaking in bacta but
it's clear that he's got revenge
on his mind
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you